the one that many people sending email
so it was kind of which way is it going
to go we'll go with the obviously
clearly better way of starting with a
big name and so they seem to gone for
this way each side said they'll see the
light in to time and I sat in several
meetings where they they discuss this
and said you're all wrong eventually
just the weight of his cassette we'll do
some we we've all gone for this missus
scheme the UK and the US disagreed in
multiple ways so the internet initially
went with so originally they just had
dot Harper so you'd be at Dan Futaba Joe
it's time for Good Hope or something
like that again that wasn't going to
scale we couldn't all belong to the
Harper they split it up into several
top-level domains dot ed U was for
educational sites mostly universities
dot mil for military because obviously
this came out of the ARPANET and there
was military people dotnet was generally
for network providers comm for
commercial doctor for the government
hint for international organizations
they were thinking things like the UN
and anything else dot all for any other
organization that list is now growing
they've added all sorts of other things
to it but this is the way it kind of
worked so you were at Angel adopted you
amazon.com you were split up in those
sort of top-level domains in the UK they
decided and actually across most of
Europe they decided they were going to
go more hierarchical so there would be a
UK domain in France there's a lot fo and
then below the UK they had Co for
commercials and AC for academic
community and then you you divide it up
between that and for the longest time
there was only UK AC basically in the UK
as it was a one commercial domain just
to sort of prove it worked for a longest
while however the bad thing for us is
that and unfriendly was this these sort
of adult we could sort of live with that
because you know knew to send all the UK
stuff to the UK and any of these other
things you'd send off mostly to the
ARPANET or the Internet as it was
beginning to come but the thing we did
weirdly in the UK was to flip everything
around so this would be UK AC not not CS
for the computer science that not again
and if you're in the internet it would
be the other way around CS does not hey
Z okay they both had good reasons for
doing this both of them said it was much
more natural way to write the addresses
you would always start with the most
significant thing work your way down no
you'd always have the most significant
thing on the right hand side and work it
down that way this cause does no end of
issues in our mail routing tables
because typically users would pick up
business cards or they'd be sent to
dresses in email addresses not actually
in the headers but oh you can contact me
it in Berkeley dot head you say we would
type in you know Eric Berkeley got head
to you or whatever and we have to sort
this mess out within the routing tables
and mostly it was okay if it sort of
ended without you that was okay but
there were a few palindromic addresses
and we really hit when checklist
Czechoslovakia I can hardly say that
joined and they have the top-level
domain at CS so now you could actually
pass this either way this could be
somewhere in Czechoslovakia and where it
could be somewhere in the UK so this had
it even more complexity to the mail
tables which were already pretty complex
so you take an address and you try and
pause it both ways you'd say does it
work this way if not you'd flip it
around say does it work that way if you
got a hit that was all well and good and
you where to send it but typically you
didn't have a complete list of every
place in the known world so you'd start
chopping bits off you chop off the CS
and say do I know about Nottingham in AC
UK and if you didn't know about that you
chopped off the next bit and saying well
what about UK AC or just UK so you work
your way back up but you have to do it
each way so in actual fact you chop off
the CS going this way and then you chop
off the UK going the other way and see
if that made sense and then you start
chopping off in the opposite directions
and you keep working up until you found
the longest possible match
and I don't think we ever really ended
up with completely palindromic addresses
but that was more by luck than judgment
really you know that it was just crazy
times you get these addresses you have
to flip them around and we'd give
weightings to some of them and sometimes
you'd fill out your table more than you
need it just to say no this place
although it looks ambiguous no it really
does need to go off to the internet and
not to come to this way or that way I
think this sort of formally died out
somewhere in the nineteen nineties buts
but it lasted fro no end time and most
nearly everywhere else kind of ended up
with the the US version and even if they
had their own names like France or
Greece or or whatever their own
top-level domain they tended to stick
with this one so it was specifically UK
problem of trying to get all that sorted
out really a problem we could have done
without sort of an ending problem isn't
it oh absolutely it was called big
Indian versus Little Indians it's still
the same on the internet do you if
you're sending like an integer which is
typically often composed of four bytes
do you send the biggest one first or the
smallest one first luckily I think those
are the two only options now but this
this one was sort of a problem around
making I don't know why we didn't yes
well it wasn't really clear at the time
who was going to win out and they came
up with this and me the internet and
said this is gonna win this is gonna be
it this is the obvious way to do things
no no it's much easier to do it
hierarchically and in some there is some
sympathy with that you know you can sort
of divulge this the UK and say right the
UK you sort out what goes on below UK
because this what's a bit more awkward
if you learned it's sort out who grants
names willow add you it's sort of an
international thing same with gods and
things like that so it's much easier to
do it by country because you've usually
got some body there that can divide it
up and there should be 32 bits there now
each of these bits has a number
associated with it so this would be
considered bit
zero and this will be considered bit 31
and then we can count down so this is
then bit 24 that's bit 23 16 and 15 and
then that